as a general rule trump plus india is a
very dangerous combination likely to
lead to complete and total humiliation
trump when he is alongside indian prime
minister modi will often praise
extraordinarily authoritarian ideas you
might remember that once donald trump
spoke in india and mispronounced
everything
and the crowd literally started to flee
you might remember our 2020 video indian
crowd flees as trump mispronounces
everything remember trump trying to
pronounce indian names
[Applause]
yeah that that was a hell of an event
namaste
so anyway trump went on indian tv
yesterday uh ndtv new delhi television
and just drops humiliating whopper after
whopper now i still don't really know
why he's appearing on these shows
i think that
there's probably less interest lately in
having him on
you know what might be more mainstream
american outlets that's an interesting
question in and of itself but donald
trump appearing alongside the indian
prime minister modi and trump says a lot
of crazy things including that the
united states is quote going to hell
overall the president trump that's the
question that keeps coming up that in a
democracy india is considered the
world's largest democracy you're the
world's oldest and that's why we have
this relationship the democracies
function on the principle that the
losing side concedes the defeat and the
winning side i agree with it takes over
when you lose in this case you haven't
con i mean in a sense you still haven't
accepted the outcome of 2020 you still
because i look at the rules take a look
at what happened
two weeks ago it came out the head of
facebook zuckerberg said the they had a
facebook guys be i came to him
and told him there's
russian disinformation
don't say anything and they went to the
media and they suppressed it
that's a major form this isn't just
ballot stuffing what they're doing right
was so bad and what they're doing uh see
if you can follow his explanation
through the entire clip i dare you is it
disgrace to our country uh and nobody
did anything about it and it made they
say the pollsters say it made from a 10
to a 20 point difference
can you imagine can you imagine what
he's claiming there a 20-point
difference because of uh of of the
hunter biden laptop zuckerberg thing so
instead of biden winning by
well i don't even know what was the
percentage six trump was going to win
the popular vote by 14. i mean it's it's
an absurd claim in the election outcome
oh it was a tremendous they suppressed
all of that information
probably illegally i assume it was
illegally done but it should have never
done next
you you think that this is a kind of a
problematic area when
you have an election outcome and then
absolutely not one side doesn't accept
no absolutely not you know i mean we all
know there is a lot of fraud voter fraud
in the united states you know all the
democrat-run cities uh democrat-run
districts sorry and by the way if i said
earlier that uh
um trump appeared alongside modi this is
not modi it's very clearly not modi and
i don't know why i have that in my notes
but this is shalab kumar the republican
hindu coalition founder this is not modi
i was misinformed and i apologize for
that we know that their counties this
time because of the pandemic it was much
bigger
it was much bigger
that's what essentially happened now if
i don't you know first of all let me
also tell you that hindu americans
and india in general they don't give a
hoot about this i'm in the community i
go there travel there every day they
don't give up
he feels strongly about it so yes he
does feel strongly about it this now
really devolves into just like a mess of
a conversation thanks you know what i
feel strongly about our country and our
country is going to hell there it is it
is going to hell ladies and gentlemen
that's what i feel strongly about and
when i look at what's happened
to the u.s when you look at what's
happened in two years to the united
states we've never been in a position
like this ever
but you know some would say president
trump that this this idea of a of a kind
of a stolen or an illegal election
can have consequences in terms of what
happened in in january 6th some would
say as a consequence of that that there
was actual violence yeah
well democrats have said it even that
democrats have said it for a long time
about different elections what is he
talking about they went out and they
said the 2016 election was stolen the
same people that now complain and of
course this is a false equivalency the
idea that there was an influence
campaign by other countries who
preferred trump over hillary clinton
is not the literal theft of an election
in the way that trump is claiming there
was fraud
we're big complainers about 2016. they
say i stole the election in 2016 which i
didn't do but this and by the way
hillary conceded like hours after the
results voices that you hear said no no
there's tremendous proof there's
tremendous evidence and again go back to
just
two weeks ago when zuckerberg said he
was told russian misinformation don't
say anything sure don't say anything
until after the election
yeah so there's the i mean just a
bizarre interview here's just one other
clip in which trump was asked about
2024. let me just ask you to see
both of you back together again
is this all an indication that
you are now set on the road to 2024.
momentum everyone wants me to run i'm
leading in the polls and every poll
republican polls and in democrat polls
and now that's obviously not true
earlier i told you about a new poll in
which joe biden is leading by six in the
hypothetical matchup but reality does
not matter i'll make a decision in the
very
near future i suspect and i think that a
lot of people are going to be very happy
but we've been friends for a long time
we've been friends from before the last
campaign in 2016 and then 2020 uh
and i've had a great relationship to
india and to
prime minister
modi we were we've been friends and i
think he's a great guy and doing a
terrific job
it's not an easy job he's got so uh but
we've known each other a long time good
man right that's an interesting thing
you said that you said you're still
making up your mind but a lot of people
will be happy with the decision i think
so a lot of people will be and a couple
of people will be unhappy
okay this is quite an interesting uh
hint that we've got there charlotte you
think it's now almost a done deal that
president trump is
going to run again and should he run
again is he is he the obvious choice of
course he should run again that's our
view and then you know it'll be great if
he runs again i mean our community they
will just love to have uh yeah the
indian community will just absolutely
love trump and the hindu community will
love trump by the way
two communities that don't particularly
love trump but that's the claim that's
being made
what a wild interview truly bizarre
stuff and again this this
you know the right used to claim very
loudly
no matter what ever happens in the
united states you never say america
isn't great you never say america is
downhill or going bad or whatever
and now it's completely acceptable among
these folks to say no no no america
sucks now you need me to fix it and make
it good america's going to hell in the
bush era
republicans would say you never say that
very very different republican party at
this point in time
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the david pakman show you can find
videos about it and that's why i protect
myself now using aura our sponsor aura
is identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and social security
numbers and will send you alerts quickly
to your phone and email aura also gives
you near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries like if someone was
opening a loan or a credit card in your
name and if you sign up at aura.com
pacman you will get a free two-week
trial which you can use to see if your
login credentials have been leaked
online
i would want to know that right away use
the link below